okay our next speaker is becoming a
Hillsdale regular we're glad he could be
with us again John Goodman is president
of the Goodman Institute for Public
Policy Research he received his PhD in
economics from Columbia University and
dr. Goodman previously served for many
years as the president of the National
Center for Policy Analysis he's taught
at several colleges and universities
including the university of dallas and
as a recipient of the dunkin black award
for his work on public choice economics
he testifies frequently before Congress
on the topic of health care reform he's
on radio and television all the time he
writes in many for many periodicals
investors business daily USA Today in
Forbes among many others he's the author
of numerous studies on health policy and
many books including the best-selling
book patient power solving America's
health care crisis so he's well
qualified to be one of the leaders in
the effort today to repeal and replace
the Affordable Care Act today he's going
to offer us some thoughts on that
subject the title of his presentation is
Obamacare and its alternatives please
welcome John Goodman
Wow okay after an introduction like that
it makes you feel like you should run
for office I'm I'm John Goodman I
approve that message actually I thought
our staff was being a little bit
generous when we suggested some of those
remarks down but I enjoyed hearing every
word of it now on my way up here
somebody said be sure that your cell
phone is turned off and I said well why
would I want to do that I mean you can
have an emergency right in the middle of
a speech right no actually the reason I
have my phone with me and it is turned
off by the way it's illustrate a point
there are more cell phones in the United
States and there are people even the
panhandler out there on the street
corner probably has a cell phone but he
probably doesn't have very good access
to health care if something goes wrong
with my cell phone in dallas texas there
are a dozen places i can step into
without an appointment and get pretty
speedy repairs high quality low cost
there are some places that will even
send a repair person to my condo repair
my iphone in my home there's a national
chains called I hospital people who work
for to call to eye doctors and yet if
something happens to me did you know
that the average weight in the United
States to see a new doctors three weeks
in Boston where we were told they had
universal coverage even before there was
Obamacare the average wait to see new
doctor is two months and amazingly one
out of every ten people that goes to who
go to an emergency room for care turn
around and leave without ever seeing a
dr. just because they get tired of
waiting in some places is one in five
which is about what it is in Canada now
my question to you is why is the market
so kind to my phone so mean to me and I
think the answer is that this iphone is
produced and repaired in a real market
with real prices or entrepreneurs know
if they solve our problems they can make
millions of dollars whereas over in
health care we have so suppress the
market year after year decade after
decade that no one ever sees a real
price for anything
no patient no doctor no employer no
employee we like to think that our
system is really different from the
Canadian system but the truth of matter
is it's about 80% the same in both
countries the primary way we pay for
healthcare is with time and not with
money in Canada if you go to the doctor
it's free in the United States if you go
the doctor it's almost free every time
we spend a dollar at a doctor's office
only ten cents is coming out of our own
pocket the other ninety cents is paid
for by a third-party payer employer
insurance company or the government have
you ever noticed that when you visit
another professional a lawyer and
accountant engineer architect when we go
to their office that exterior ariel's
called a reception area right but when
you go to the doctor's office what do
you call it a waiting for there's a
reason for that now we've bought into
the same notion that all the other
developed countries have bought into and
that is that people should never have to
choose between money between health care
and other uses of money and what we
forget is that when we suppress the
marketplace when we suppress real prices
what we do is we elevate the importance
of all the non market barriers to care
now what are non market barriers to care
well how long does it take you on the
telephone to make an appointment with a
doctor how many days or weeks you have
to wait until you see the doctor how
long does it take you to get from your
home or your office to the doctor's
office and back and while you're there
how long do you have to wait before
you're actually treated these are non
market barriers to care and there's a
lot of evidence which we could talk
about that these non market barriers are
bigger obstacle to care than the fee
that the doctor actually charges and
that's not just for the middle class
it's also for low income people there
are in the United States about 50
million people who are on food stamps
and people who have food stamps can walk
into any supermarket you and I can walk
into they can buy just about any product
that we buy they're paying the same
price that we pay when they get to the
checkout counter and the old days they
put the food sting
down with dollar bills on top of it
these days they have a card but the main
point is that you never hear it said
that low-income people do not have
access to supermarkets the United States
I mean the worst that can happen is they
have to get on a bus and go a couple of
miles but you never hear of a
supermarket saying we aren't taking any
more food stamp customers right but over
in health care there are about 65
million people now on Medicaid and
mainly they're the same people and on
Medicaid what is the biggest problem
people have it's finding a doctor who
will see them I was in Massachusetts not
long ago and I had a female cab driver
and she told me she was on mass health
which is Massachusetts Medicaid and I
said well how's it going she said well
she had to go down a list of 20 doctors
before she found one who would see her
and I said well you're going down the
yellow pages and she said no no I going
down the list that MassHealth gave me
that's what they call universal coverage
in the state of Massachusetts now when
the Medicaid patients can't find a
doctor and by the way it's not just
Medicaid I was reading the paper this
morning that a lot of the patients who
get private insurance and the Obamacare
exchanges are having the same problem
because they have really high
deductibles which they can't afford so
they go for free care at the community
health centers and at the safety net
hospitals their emergency rooms by the
way emergency room traffic is up since
we got Obamacare it's not down for toy
20 million people additional with
additional insurance but more people
going to the emergency room now while
that's happening by the way in my city
Parkland Hospital is our major safety
net hospital and if you walk in to
Parkland Hospital if you're not bleeding
all over the floor it would not be
unusual for you to wait four or five or
six hours before you're seeing depending
on the day of the week and the time of
the day that's what rationing buy rating
waiting really means for low-income
folks now while all that's going on we
have in the United States today 2,000
walk-in clinics
and in the CVS pharmacies are called
minute clinics and the reason for that
name minute clinic is because they want
to convey to you that they know your
time is valuable as well as your money
it's a lot of evidence that the minute
clinic quality is actually greater that
they follow best practices better than
traditional primary care physicians for
those problems that they're qualified to
deal with these are nurses following
computerized protocol now we have low
cost medicine we have available medicine
but the problem is in Dallas Texas where
I live the charge for the minute clinic
for an ear ache or a sore throat would
be about $75 and medicaid pays about
half that and that would be about the
same all over the country medicaid pays
too far below the mediclinic price for
mini clinic to take the medicaid
patients so it doesn't we could greatly
expand access to health care in this
country for low-income families by just
allowing them to purchase health care
the way they purchase food and yet we
don't do that not only do not do it it's
not even seriously considered if we want
to solve our health care problems we
have to liberate the patient and then
the next thing we have to do is liberate
the doctor doctors are the only
professionals in our society who are not
free to repackage and reprice the
services of the offer to the market
every other professional the lawyers
accountants the architects if demand
changes of technology changes if
anything changes they can change what
they offer they can change the price
that doctors cannot their slaves to a
third-party payer system now wonder if
any of you have ever noticed that
doctors don't like to talk to you on the
phone you ever noticed that you must
have been a hundred years since all the
other professionals discovered the phone
it's a really handy device for talking
to clients so but but not doctors do any
of you know why that is
who said they don't get paid if you're
absolutely right over why is that well
medicare has about 7500 tasks that it
pays doctors to do is the worst way to
pay any professional but 7,500 things
they pay doctors to do next to each one
of them there's a price and when
somebody threw up the list they just
forgot the phone this is one really one
example of why it's so dumb to pay
professionals in this way all right so
we get to the end of the 20th century
narrowly discovers email even my corner
liquor store started emailing me if see
if they have a bottle of wine that I
might like by the way the minute clinic
emails me you know it's fall they say
you know your children are going back to
school they need this or that or it's
flu season but my doctor doesn't email
me why is that you know you were so good
last time this is this this pop quiz is
easy because you just keep repeating
that answer you're gonna get an a here
oh yeah you know I noticed that a number
of you here in the medical profession
you either are or have been this named
Jeffrey brim Renner ring a bell with
anybody any of them how about the term
hot spots Brenner lives in Camden New
Jersey and I'm told that this is one of
the poorest places in the whole United
States he's a scientist he's a doctor
he's trying to understand what's going
on there he goes down the hospital
records he discovers that one percent of
all the people living in Camden are
responsible for thirty percent of all
the hospital spending in a given year so
he starts looking into one percent he
discovers this one guy who weighs more
than 600 pounds and this guy is an
alcoholic he's a drug addict he's
diabetic he spends half a year in the
hospital and the rest of year he's
abusing himself so Brenner takes this
guy under his arm and he gets him off
drugs gives him off alcohol gets him
going to AAA he discovers the guy's a
Christian he gets him going to church
he signs him up for some welfare so you
can have some financial stability in his
life and pretty soon the guy isn't going
in the hospital anymore so this this
this once a very very expensive patient
it turns out that his expenses are going
down down down and saving tens of
thousands of dollars now Brenner
discovered that you know that this is
such a wonderful discovery for him he
set up a clinic and got some money and
he has other doctors helping him and now
they have lots and lots of patients that
they're carrying for in this way in fact
Brenner told me he can drive down the
streets of Camden and point to whole
buildings and tell you how much the
whole building is costing you as
taxpayers through Medicare or Medicaid
and that's where the term hotspots came
from he discovered that sick people live
near each other I never quite understood
that but any bet they do so my question
to you though is this here is Brenner
now today saving you as taxpayers
probably millions of dollars doing what
he does and in return for all that how
much do you think that Medicare gives
Brenner somebody said nothing right spot
on and how about Medicaid how much you
think Medicaid gives him back nothing
and so now the question is why is that
and the answer is because what I just
described to you a moment ago is not
according to Medicare real health care
in fact you might call it social work I
mean just getting people to clean up
their act get off drugs get off alcohol
do some sensible things all of a sudden
their health care costs are going down
their health gets better but that's not
on the list of the 7500 things that
Medicare pays for now back when the bush
people were in office I went and told
them about this and I said you know what
you guys should do you you should give
Brenner a million dollars and they there
was stunned of silence and then somebody
said well why would we want to do that
and he's already doing what we wanted to
do see this is the way bureaucrats thing
all of you are entrepreneurs I know you
don't wouldn't think that way so I
patiently explained you know because if
if doctors throughout America learned
that they could be paid a different way
all they have to do is come to to
Washington say pay me a different way
and I'll save you money i'll raise
quality we ought to we all take the deal
well that was the most radical idea they
had ever heard of and of course they
hadn't heard of obamacare yeah that was
just around the corner if we want to
reform our health care system we have to
free the patient we have to free the
doctor and we have to free the
entrepreneur you know there's man his
wife they went to a doctor and he was in
really bad shape and his arteries were
clogged and his heart was poor shape and
the doctor called the life over and said
you know your husband is a bad shape and
what you need to do is make his life as
comfortable as possible so don't nag at
him don't fuss at him don't argue with
him whatever he wants to eat fix it for
him for once sex give him sex just make
his life as comfortable and pleasant as
you can so on the way home the man turns
to his wife says you know you and the
doctor had quite a long conversation
what did he say to you he said you're
going to die
I'm sometimes asked if the free market
can work in healthcare and my response
is free the free market is the only
thing it works in healthcare show me a
health care sector where there's no blue
cross no Medicare and no employer and
we're probably looking at a health care
market that works pretty well just
looking around the room I'm going to
guess that most of you don't know very
much about the market for cosmetic
surgery but but just give it another 10
years and even you will be interested
all right here's a market where there's
no Blue Cross there's no third-party
payer and what do you get you get
package prices you know price covering
everything the doctor the nurse in
essence is the facility you have price
competition and over the last 15 years
the real price of cosmetic surgery has
gone down down down even as the real
price of every other kind of surgery has
gone up up up and and this is with huge
increase in demand huge technological
change of the type work told increases
costs everywhere else LASIK surgery same
thing you get package prices have price
competition you have quality competition
over the last 10-15 years twenty five
percent decrease in the real price of
this procedure here's another market
that seems to work very very well we've
already mentioned the walk-in clinics
are XCOM came into existence in order to
compete with local pharmacies their
error rate is lower the prices are
cheaper every one of these examples i'm
talking about came into existence in
order to cater to people paying out of
pocket with their own money they may now
take some insurance but they wouldn't
exist if they're only customers Blue
Cross they exist and they do what they
do to cater to real people paying the
real money out of their own pockets
medical tourism down in Grand Cayman
just a plane right away you can get
surgery that's really higher quality
than what you'd expect in the United
States and by that I mean lower
infection rate lower readmission
lower mortality rate and one third of
the cost all you have to do is get on a
plane and go there what are they doing
they're doing the same thing that
happened in these other examples i just
gave you and that is they're competing
for people spending with their own
dollars if we want the health care
system to work we need to get government
out of the way we need to reduce the
role of the third-party payers we need
to empower patients as much as possible
and let the market work and that's what
Obamacare is not doing now I'm helping
Pete sessions in the house he's on the
Rules Committee heavy chairman of the
Rules Committee and part of the house
leadership and Bill Cassidy in the
Senate who probably knows more about
health care than anybody in the Senate
and we're putting together an
alternative to Obamacare it's taken six
years to get this done not that I've
been working on for six years but for
six years Republicans have have not
produced a credible alternative and none
of our three Republican candidates have
a credible alternative either nor does
Bernie Sanders for that matter now I've
got a list of 25 problems of bhama care
and we're going to solve every single
one of them but I won't go through all
25 with you right now but let me just
mention for really big big ones number
one Obamacare forces you to buy an
insurance package designed in Washington
and the cost of that package is going to
grow twice as fast as your income now
Obama didn't create the fundamental
problem nor did Congress has been going
on for 40 years or 40 years the real
cost of health care per person in this
country has been growing at about twice
the rate of our income and you don't
have to be a mathematician or an
accountant to know that if that
continues eventually healthcare crowds
out everything else we're consuming and
as a matter of fact if we continue on
the path that we're on by the time
today's college students get to the
retirement age there won't be anything
else left there they won't have any
money for food or clothing or housing
but that really great health care
clearly that's an impossible
come and yet that's what Obamacare does
and here is something that I haven't
seen anybody else comment on except me
and that is their these secret little
provisions in the obamacare bill that
protect the government from all this and
what are they well then in Medicare
there's a provision that says in
Medicare going forward is supposed to
grow no faster than our income forever
so when Obama says he's really helped
Medicare yes he's helped it in the sense
that there may be seniors who don't get
the care they need because they're going
to limit the spending and then Medicaid
Hospital spending is also going forward
past the next few years for ever going
to grow no faster than national income
and finally after 2018 the government
subsidies and the exchanges the
subsidies that we know help people buy
private insurance they are going to grow
no faster than national income so if I
can do a visual for you health care
costs are going to go like this the
government's contribution to them are
going to go like this and they're going
to be shifting more and more cost to the
private sector that clearly is a problem
that can't go on needs solving now
number two we have this bizarre system
of subsidies in most places a family at
one hundred thirty-eight percent of
poverty can go into Medicaid most states
and a family of four gets insurance that
I'm going to say it's worth about eight
thousand dollars if this family earns
one more dollar then they get kicked out
of Medicaid they go into the exchange
and let's say now they have a plan
that's worth about twelve thousand
dollars they have to pay about eight or
nine hundred dollars out of their own
pocket for it so back on Medicaid let's
say they were getting an eight thousand
dollar gift in the obamacare exchange
they get an eleven thousand dollar gift
but the employees of this hotel I don't
know if you've noticed as you walk
around look around and most of these
people are only making fifteen twenty
dollars an hour if that you know the
maids the Busboys and so forth
there at the same income level and
Obamacare legislation is trying to force
these employees in this hotel to buy
expensive health insurance and they get
no new help from government so we have
eight thousand dollar gift 11,000 our
gift over here the hotel if they don't
do what they're told they all get fined
that's not fair but there's something
worse than not being fair it's going to
upset our whole economy because as
employers discover that everybody who's
below average wages is really better off
in the exchange or in Medicaid and
everybody who's above average wages is
better off getting health insurance at
work and there's evidence that most
people are ignoring that companies are
really changing who they employee and
how they form based on these health
insurance subsidies and that's bad you
know if we want to have an economy
that's vigorous and competitive and
compete in the world economy we need
these decisions to be made on economic
costs and benefits not on costs and
benefits from health insurance subsidies
by the government now number three we
have in the exchanges a race to the
bottom what I call race to the bottom
and all of you have heard about some of
the problems there what I mean by race
to the bottom is we have a bunch of
insurers and you know you don't really
have to be in the insurance market to
understand this if you imagine you're an
insurance company and you have to take
every enrollee that applies for your
plan at the same premium no matter how
sick no matter how well you won't have
to think about that very long to realize
that you have your best chance of making
a profit on healthy people and likely
you will suffer severe losses if the
enrollee is sick so what all the plans
are doing is they're trying to attract
the healthy and avoid the sick now the
insurance guys figured out a long time
ago the healthy people tend to buy on
price and so how do you get the price
down well you have a high deductible you
have a narrow network the way you get a
narrow network is you throw out a really
low fee and just take the doctors who
accept it take the facilities the
hospitals who will accepting and those
typically tend not to be the very best
doctors for the best facilities so
narrow networks tend to leave out the
best cancer doctors the best cancer
facilities where I live it leave leaves
out UT Southwestern Medical School which
is our premier health center in dallas
and there's not one plan in the exchange
in dallas that covers UT Southwestern so
that's what we're getting a race to the
bottom and it's like a game of musical
musical chairs nobody wants the sick
person and by the way the perverse
incentives don't stop at the point of
entry you know after you've entered the
plan the perverse incentives are still
there if you're healthy they want you
the incentives is to overspend on the
healthy to keep the ones they have and
attract more of them next time around
and under provide to the sick because
they don't want the ones they have and
they certainly don't want to attract any
more of them and then problem number 4
that's the problem i just described is
on the seller side of the market their
gaming the system then over on the buyer
side of the market there's a similar
perverse incentive and that is to wait
until you get sick to buy health
insurance and this is happening a lot
and how do I know that because all the
insurance companies are complaining
about it they say the people that wait
until June and figure out some some
excuse to get around the rules and buy
insurance outside of open season they're
sicker than other patients and
furthermore the sick people go in and
they get their care and then they drop
their coverage you know between January
in September we're losing a fourth of
people exchange they just quit paying
premiums now in Massachusetts these are
called jumpers and dumpers people jump
in when they get sick they kiss their
medical care they get their bills paid
and then they dump the plan after after
they get well again but if we all do
that what's going to happen the only
people with health insurance will be
sick if the only people with health
insurance will be sick the premiums have
to be really really high for anyone to
stay in the business so we have
potentially now a death spiral because
of all this and what happens in a death
spiral is your your population just gets
sicker and sicker and as that happens
you have to keep raising your premiums
higher and higher and you go into what
we would call in any other industry just
bankruptcy and there's severe danger of
that but even if we don't go all the way
into a death spiral we have truly
dysfunctional system where everybody is
facing perverse incentives you know the
Yakuza in Japan have a practice which I
think it's kind of interesting if one of
their members commits a serious mistake
you know he does he severs a finger and
then he offers the finger to his
superior by way of atonement and I've
often thought if the members of Congress
remembers the bomb administration had as
much honor as as the members of Japanese
mafia we'd have a lot less
finger-pointing in Washington all right
what are we going to do about it well we
have a bill I said it hadn't been
working for six years but had been
working for a year on this and spent a
long time with legislative council
because doing a lot of new things that
have never been done before it's easy
for legislative council if they can copy
some previous bill that had a lot of the
same language but for us it was almost
all new and one of the things we're
doing is we're replacing the all the
hodgepodge system we have now with just
a uniform universal tax credit same for
everyone it's beginning next year will
be twenty five hundred dollars for an
adult and eight thousand dollars for a
family of four and that's your tax
credit and it's refundable so if you're
not paying taxes you still get it
provided that you pay premiums with it
or make deposits to health savings
accounts and then we're going to get
government out of the way and so instead
of telling people what they have to buy
we're going to let the market determine
what it can do for the money that people
have and our minimum tax credit is sort
of tied to Medicaid
there was most people with it would have
no trouble buying a plan that looks like
our best managed private Medicaid plans
it's not a plan that most of you would
want to be in but it's it's the minimum
benefit it's what Democrats consider to
be an acceptable level of care so we so
we have a minimum that everybody is
entitled to there's no reason for
anybody to be uninsured but but we saw a
huge problem and in the process we're
going to do something for employers that
no one else has had the encouraged to do
because of John McCain's poor poor
experience of two thousand eight
election John McCain advocated a
universal tax credit and Barack Obama or
his campaign demagogue the whole issue
spent a hundred million dollars on
commercials that claim that McCain was
going to tax their buddies insurance and
you can go on the internet and see that
commercial today by the way its most
downloaded commercials everything
running a political campaign okay with
that problem in our background even the
Obamacare advisors prefer the tax credit
approach and that includes seek Emanuel
who was that White House doctor who
helped give us Obamacare Jason Furman
who's the chief economist for Obama they
all understand the tax credit approach
is better and let me just explain just
briefly what this does for the employer
and the employee currently if we have a
family plan it costs twenty thousand
dollars under the current system and
employer and employee are buying at all
pre-tax dollars every one of those
dollars is getting a subsidy and the
subsidy is avoiding payroll and income
taxes and if you live in New York City
and you have a decent income you're in
the fifty percent tax bracket which
means every single dollar you're
spending on health insurance through
your employer is getting a 50-percent
subsidy from the government and that
means the health insurance only has to
be worth fifty cents to you to be
preferable to a dollar of wages now what
we're going to do is push the tax
benefits up front
so the first eight thousand dollars it's
a dollar for dollar subsidy and the next
twelve gets nothing so for the average
worker this is just a wash because we're
just taking money in the system and
pushing it up front but what it means is
that it's only the first dollars of
insurance the core insurance you want
everybody to have that's what we're
going to subsidize and all the marginal
insurance which contains the benefits of
questionable value people do that with
unsubsidized dollars and what that means
is if they find waste in their health
plan every dollar waste can be converted
to a dollar of take-home pay you know
it's talking to Donald Trump's economist
just the other day I said your candidate
doesn't have a decent health plan
norther the other two but here's an idea
go with this tax credit approach and I
think you could credibly claim the
average family would save two thousand
dollars that's two thousand dollars
added to take home pay you all are out
there talking about incomes and how
these stagnated in all this here's a
practical proposal that gets support
from the left and the right it's a
common sense approach to health care
that would increase family income the
other common sense propose I made was a
corporate flat tax a nine percent
across-the-board tax on corporate
profits instead of what we have today
the best tax economist in the whole
country that I work with say that would
save about three thousand dollars for
the average household so there's there's
a five-thousand-dollar benefit to blue
collar workers that we can credibly make
it's not just some right-wing ideas not
trickle down economics it these are two
proposals that have broad support but so
far I can't get through to them okay
then on the exchange we're going to have
real market for insurance where we have
real risk adjustment so the healthier
just as attractive to the insurers as
the sick we're going to use the Medicare
Advantage approach how many of you are
in Medicare Advantage
so do you when a Medicare enrollee goes
into American Medicare Advantage program
the government makes a risk-adjusted
payment to that plan so if the senior
has a lot of health problems that plan
may get sixty thousand dollars and their
plans that specialize in special needs
patience and and they try to attract
people with health problems because you
get a lot of money for those patients
we're going to use that same risk
adjustment mechanism in our new market
for health insurance but we're not going
to have Medicare dictate everything
we're going to let the insurer's improve
on that risk adjustment system working
at free market risk adjustment and then
on gaming the system on the part of the
buyers and then I'm going to quit here
in just a second let you all ask
questions because I understand that this
is a group that likes to ask questions i
right about that okay we figured out
with seniors we don't need mandates
right if your senior you can go into
Medicare Part B you can go to Medicare
Part D there's no mandate right it's
guaranteed issue Community Rating
Medigap market same thing but if you
don't sign up when you're eligible then
you get penalized in the Medigap market
if you don't sign up when you're
eligible you can be underwritten which
means you can be charged a premium that
reflects your expected costs so we know
how to solve these problems without
oppressive mandates and and that's what
we're going to do in our new health bill
now let me just wrap up and let you ask
me a few questions by saying that I was
introduced as the father of health
savings accounts to most people health
savings accounts are financial concept
they could create good financial
incentives for patients and they do all
that but for me the most important
aspect of the HSA is not the financial
aspect the most important aspect for me
has always been the power aspect the
health care system can be cold and
different uncaring unresponsive and
probably all of you have experienced all
of those things
and so it occurs to me though that if
you control the money and you have the
power to make decisions for yourself
that system is going to work better for
you than if you surrender the money and
the power to some impersonal bureaucracy
thank you all very much good time for a
few questions try to pick out the easy
questions we well since you seem so
novels about Congress here's an easy one
for you I don't see how this medical
problem called Obamacare was a surprise
to anyone they had to see it coming why
are the both parties let's start with
the Republicans sat on their Duff for
decades and then nothing about it and
now after its put in place they hardly
explain why it should be withdrawn just
they don't like it well the main problem
price actually booth both parties but
the main problem of the Republican Party
is that someone like me can go in and
tell them how you can perform the system
in a free enterprise way minimize the
role of government streamline the role
of government and then after I leave the
office i call it the insurance companies
like what do you think of Goodman's
plant well we don't like that now call
the hospitals Lee and they're too tied
into all the special interests and what
we all need to understand is that reform
means people have to change what they're
doing and most people don't want to
change what they're doing especially if
they're in the insurance business but
also in the hospital business and these
other areas so we haven't had the kind
of leaders Paul Ryan is a good person in
this respect he's the one who carried my
bill a couple years ago so Paul and I go
way way back and if they're more people
like Paul this would be easier but but
they're all cow held by the special
interests who contributed their
campaigns
why do we all have to take Medicare why
can't we have private choice so our
physicians will accept our insurance
because if Medicare doesn't pay their
fee then the co insurance doesn't pay
their fee and some hospitals are
beginning to not take Medicare now our
bill that I described to you a few
minutes ago does not change Medicare
it's not that Medicare doesn't need
changing it's just that we thought you
know if we get obamacare change that's
that's enough in one bill but at Health
Affairs Tom saving and I who is a former
trustee of Medicare listed ten reforms
to Medicare all of which we think would
help seniors and make the system more
viable and one of the changes is what
you're suggesting let's let's free the
patients and let them negotiate with
doctors and we don't have to do this for
everybody at once we can selectively do
this we also want to free the concierge
doctors in fact I don't see any reason
why Medicare shouldn't pay a fourth or a
half of the concierge fee because you
get better care you get more efficient
care those doctors do talk on the phone
they do email how many of you have a
concierge doc you pay the rest of you
better start thinking about this because
I promise you it's going to get harder
and harder and harder as we ration by
waiting oh I can I guess i can't call on
people you guys have to do this I not
are you familiar with Bert mccomas his
website medical self-sufficiency com no
okay he spoke at the American
Association of Physicians and Surgeons
aaps you're no damn sure knew the
renegade doctors that want to eliminate
third-party payers from the
doctor-patient relationship anyway this
particular website educates people who
don't want to buy third-party payer
insurance of any kind and
gives them tips on how to be able to be
a self pay individual but do it in an
affordable manner and it might be
something that people could check out
and find out a little more about but
okay I don't think we can get rid of
third-party payer insurance completely
because some things are really expensive
and a twenty-five-thousand-dollar knee
replacement or hip replacement that's
money most people don't have but I do
think we can empower the patient I tell
you quick story about wellpoint in
California they looked at all the
hospitals in the state and their client
is CalPERS which are all the employees
and their dependents the State of
California's and hundreds of thousands
of people and they discovered that for
the hip and knee replacements there were
about 40 hospitals that consistently
came in at below thirty thousand dollars
and the others were all over the map you
know from 15 200 and so what they said
with the approval of the state of
California to their employees if you go
to one of these 46 hospitals we have the
traditional deal you can go out of
network if you want to but all we're
going to pay is thirty thousand dollars
so within a year the average
out-of-network charge fell by a third
within two years it was less than thirty
thousand dollars so here are patients
going into the mark telling the doctors
and hospitals how much money they have
to spend all of a sudden the market is
changing rapidly and that's with
wellpoint not ever writing a letter not
ever picking the tab the telephone not
negotiating with a single hospital is
just letting markets work I understand
that before there were Obamacare
mandates there were mandates in many of
the states if not all of the states that
all of professional organizations
lobbied for to get mandates for
psychiatric care podiatrist care and all
the rest if those mandates didn't exist
if Obamacare had not put any mandates on
Obamacare afoot in the Affordable Care
Act but have opened up a free market
among
d States and people were simply able to
just get the insurance they felt they
needed given their age in life and
everything and their needs would that
would that have worked as long as you
eliminate the mandates and as you say
give the patient's put the power to
decide what they need well all those
state mandates are still there by the
way and my states one of the worst I
mean we have like fifty two separate
mandates the Obamacare mandates that the
primary thing they do is force you to
buy a whole package if you don't buy at
they find you in that package by the way
is a package which is really good for
hospitals but not good say for the
employees of this hotel because what it
does is it said there's going to be no
lifetime limit and no no annual limit so
let's say that the employees of this
hotel is say basically they're young and
they're healthy and you don't have a lot
of cash so they now have a plan with a
six thousand dollar deductible if they
have a premature baby that baby costs a
million dollars the hospital is going to
get as million but they don't have the
6,000 for the deductible they couldn't
have paid the million anyway so who was
helped by that the hospital and so what
we have in our bill is a more limited
kind of insurance that people can choose
for lower income families no mandates
and it works like this for the first
fifty thousand dollars or say a hundred
thousand dollars the employees assets
and income are protected up to the limit
of the plan so the hospital so if there
were a million dollar premature baby the
hospital could not seize the assets and
it would get a hundred thousand dollars
but it wouldn't couldn't seize the
assets or the income of the family so so
we want people to be able to have
insurance that fits their financial
needs and their health care needs not
the hospital's needs maybe just say one
more thing the hospital still has a
problem how we're going to pay for these
expensive things occasionally happen but
the right solution is not to impose on
poise of this hotel insurance that
doesn't meet their needs
oh okay they seem to be a trend of the
use of dr. selling their practices and
going to work for hospitals which to me
would seem to compromise their role as
an advocate for a patient to an
insurance company because now they're in
the middle of of it I'm just wanting to
have some comments and you see that
continuing or oh it's horrible and it's
happening because Medicare pays two or
three times as much for dr. services
built through a hospital than it does
for the doctor on his own so what's he
doing he's selling out to the hospital
what happens then the hospital puts
pressure on him to keep the hospital
beds full filled because folks this is
what hospitals do they fill their beds
and if they're not filling their beds
they're not not making money so so the
whole system what you described is bad
it's contributing the cost inflation
it's the opposite direction we should we
should let the market make these
decisions not artificial subsidies
coming from government yeah a quick
comment and a quick question I see is
the difficulty in getting the liberal
left on board with the thing like this
is that I don't think and many don't
that Obamacare was about health care
whatsoever it was about redistributing
wealth but my comment is do you have any
data one way or another on the cost of
let's say a surgeon or and the and the
equality no and it's hard to get data on
costs and quality but but in the medical
tourism market they tell you what their
quality data are the health city down in
Grand Cayman will tell you what it's
rien Dre tis it will tell you it's
infection rate its mortality rate for
the different kinds of surgeries and it
will tell you a package price that's
what happens when we have real markets
let me just make a comment about the
left about a year ago I spent a whole
day at the
afl-cio building and washington and I've
never been there before and now I know
where all the union dues go is a really
nice building but we laid out our plan
for these guys and they were interested
I mean they didn't take my photograph
and put it up on the wall or anything
but nor do they kick us out on the
street and I think I believe that
business and labor and other people you
might think of as on the left can come
together on a sensible reform if we have
the right kind of leaders hi i don't
know if i miss the comet but how do you
intend to stop the people from going
into the plan when they're sick and
coming out of the plan with their na
which just creates havoc for everybody
on in terms of rates the same way that
medicare does it if if they don't sign
up and stay signed up when they're
eligible they get financially penalized
and if we're talking about Medigap
insurance in most states they can
underwrite you which means charge your
premium that reflects your real health
condition so so we can do this without
mandates we do with the seniors let's do
with everybody else we have time for one
more question thank you I'm question
regarding e over here question regarding
the role of the states in this why can I
advise why can I not buy insurance
across state lines and secondly would
medical tort reform the lower costs well
you have to stop and think what it means
to buy insurance across state lines each
state has its own mandates okay and what
to me buying cross state lines would
mean if I'm living in Texas insurer's
should be able to sell me a plan that
abides by Georgia mandates instead of
Texas mandates and if we could do that
everywhere it probably lower premiums by
about ten percent
but but you got to get the Texas
legislators to agree to that and the
reason they're unlikely to agree to it
is the reason we have so many mandates
and taxes because they gave in to all
the special interests so it's a hard
thing to to get done on tort reform I'm
a radical on tort reform I want to get
the lawyers out of this entire wing and
so so I don't like these you know camp
benefits and this and that I I want a
system where when you go to the hospital
you in the hospital sign a contract sort
of like the relationship you have with
employer under workers compensation and
if there's a medical adverse outcome
let's say you die you get certain number
of dollars you lose an arm you can
certainly you lose leg so you know
what's going to happen to you
financially if bad things happen and
this needs to be approved by the state
legislature but it's a voluntary
contract between you and the hospital
you don't like the amounts you can
double the premium and ensure on your
own for more but what that does is it
gives a hospital and economic incentive
to reduce all causes of adverse medical
outcomes not just what's called
malpractice what's called malpractice is
only twenty five percent of the bad
things that happen the other three force
or acts of god and other reasons
infections for example but what happens
if the only thing the hospital focuses
on is malpractice it'll order more tests
the doctors will and when they order
more tests they run up the risk of other
bad things happening so so in we have a
system with skewed incentives if we
don't reform at the right way we'll just
create more perverse incentives and what
I want to do is get all the incentives
right and get this out of the courthouse
and let let let economic incentives
solve our safety problem the hospital I
mentioned down in Grand Cayman they give
you a package price if there's an
infection if there's a readmission they
pay you not pay
and their readmission rates are low and
their infection rates are low because
it's in their economic self-interest to
have them low that's the answer to the
malpractice problem thank you all very
much